When you are asked a question when you are explaining something or overcoming an objection
You are not going to give an answer from you. You are going to give an answer from a client
Let me repeat that when you answer an object when somebody asks you a question
Okay, a client asks you a question. Hey, how are you different the home advisor? Hey, how does your pricing work?
Hey, how do you guys do flat fee?
Etc or when you are doing your screencast or you're overcoming an objection, you know is going to come up
Instead of answering it just blah and this is what this is the answer
You're going to take a little bit more time and you're gonna answer that question
By using a client's answer to answer that question. Okay, that might be a sound a little bit confusing. It's really really simple
Okay, let me give you an example
Client asks you you jump on the phone. You're doing your prospecting. You're hooking the business owner
Like we talked about in step three or sorry step four module four
I'm losing my numbers here in module four where you're actually hooking the business owner
You call them they're interested you go through the script and you're kind of at the end and they're one of those people that starts asking
Questions, right they keep asking questions and you're trying to like avoid it, but they keep asking
Okay, so business owner for example, they would say something like
Okay
So tell me real quick before we end this like how are you different than home advisor?
Okay, most of us would start rambling on well
We we don't we don't do shared leads number one, sir
well, I
Mean whatever the 17,000 different reasons and canned responses are we we work exclusively with one company
We make sure the leads are qualified but whatever whatever the reasons are that you give of saying you're different than home advisor
Once you respond they expect you to have a certain response like they know you've been asked
So when you say it it is what it is
But here's what you're gonna do is instead of answering that
You know answering that question just the way that that you hear it or the way you understand it
You're gonna use a client. Okay, so for example
This is how you're gonna answer instead of saying yeah
Well, we don't do exclusive leads you could say well, and this is kind of the response
I like to give is if somebody says something like that and say hey, what's the difference between you and home advisor?
Well, and I'd say something like well, basically the only thing that's the same as we work with contractors
No, but for real and then this is what I would say I'd say so I'd say no
But for real like we have a guy his name is Joe
He's he's our duct cleaning client in Chicago. You can look up his site as Chicago duct cleaning
And his biggest thing because he was working
He was actually working just like you with home advisor for like three years
His biggest thing and we just talked him last week is he's keep saying over and over is like dude
Just the fact that I don't have to worry about
Competing with four other companies in town and I have the lead exclusively to myself has made all the difference in the world
So just so you know, we work with one company exclusively and we don't share the leads
You say that guys you use it like that
It's a little bit it takes a little bit more effort of thinking and it gets it gets easier
But you use that and now it's not me saying it's Joe. It's Joe the duck cleaner in Chicago
It not only does it hold way more weight, but it also builds authority and it removes the objection of trust
Okay, it removes the objection of trust because now you're not just some random schmo
That's in his mom's basement now. You're a human being that has other clients. You're a human being that has other clients in Chicago
You're a human being that has other clients in duck cleaning, which is the same industry as this guy
So just doing that simple thing you are removing this objection. There's a huge objection of trust